hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in Aristotle's Poetics as he is
discussing plot which is the most
important aspect of tragedy according to
him one of the central features of plot
is what he calls Anna norrises and we
translate this as recognition the Anna
conveying sort of a rising up and the
you know norrises has to do with
knowledge and the way that he's actually
going to Define it is precisely that a
change a metabolic going from one state
to another in this case of ignorance
Annoy Us to knowledge gnosis of of
something so going from not knowing to
knowing and it doesn't mean having
absolute knowledge it could be just
enough to be able to figure out who
people are and what's what right and
we'll talk about the objects of it in a
moment but he he tells us two other
things that are really important it's
not just like any sort of transformation
of ignorance to knowledge like say the
process of learning things in class
although you know it could result in
that depending on who we're talking
about but more importantly it leads to
either he says friendship philia or it's
opposite uh enmity or hatred or rivalry
of each other right being being
connected to each other in positive ways
or being connected in negative ways and
this happens because you figure out who
people actually are so oh you're my
long-lost brother wow now we have you
know love between us as characters when
we didn't have this before oh you are
the person who actually killed my father
we are enemies now right so that can be
that and then it Bears
upon Prosperity or for adversity
literally it has to do with those
matters that concern
Prosperity or adversity and those terms
here are you
on so not happiness and misery but you
know being in a fortunate condition or
an unfortunate condition which could
include those those relationships and he
does tell us a few other things before
we launch into the five types that that
might be useful to bring up
he tells us that the best or the finest
the most beautiful recognition is that
which occurs simultaneously with
reversal and he says that you know the
kind of thing that we're talking about
occurs after a fashion in relation to
inanimate and even chance things but
what we're really most interested in
here is the kind of recognition that can
produce pity or fear that can get us
involved emotionally in the plot and so
he's going to talk about five different
types A little bit later on he'll you
know talk about the first the second the
uh you know third fourth and then the
best so there's actually five of them
and these are a day so these are actual
divisions into
um you know things that are distinct
from each other so interest
interestingly the first two he's going
to say are you know a techno meaning
that they're they're not artistic is how
we translate it but a better way of
understanding it is it's it's kind of
outside of the craft of the person who's
doing the artistic work the tragedy and
in this case the poet
and one of these is a little bit
counter-intuitive as we're going to see
in just a moment calling it you know
outside of the the work itself the first
one he actually says too is from
uninventiveness or a lack of
resources right
um the Opera not knowing what to do well
so it's kind of the sloppy crap work
that people who don't really know how to
write good tragedy how to write a good
plot will engage in
and so the first type is from what is
sometimes translated as tokens but a
better translation would be signs Dia
tone semayon
um so my own here is of signs right so
from or of these things and it is least
artistic According to Aristotle why
because it's easy to to do and it
doesn't always make the most sense but
it can be done better or worse and
interestingly he brings up uh Homer who
is an epic poet not a tragedy and and a
scene from well actually two scenes from
The
Odyssey in which a recognition according
to signs is going to take place a
recognition from the sign of a scar
so he tells us that some of these signs
are born with us like the spear the
earthborn bear and the earthborn are the
people who were sown as Dragon's Teeth
and rose out of the Earth in in uh you
know Greek
Legends and stuff like that
um now those would be things that they
actually can be identified by so you can
have a recognition or
um you know stars like those that
carcinus uses in fiesti's we're not
really quite sure what that that means
others are acquired he says and can be
divided into the bodily like scars
things that happen to us I suppose we
would probably in our day include
tattoos as well or brands or whatever
else happens to our body maybe moles or
things like that too right
um but then there's external ones and he
gives the example of a necklace or even
a boat that little children were kept in
so keepsakes you know a locket is is a
very popular one not in Aristotle's time
but in much later literature you see
that sort of thing and you're like holy
crap this is this person I just didn't
realize it and any goes on these can be
better or worse you know Odysseus is
differently recognized by his nurse in
the swine herd and then he says that
recognition for the sake of proof and
all of this type are less artistic but
those linked to reversal like the one in
the bath scene this is when
Odysseus's old aged nurse who's known
him since a kid is bathing him and is
like holy crap
you're Odysseus
because she recognizes a scar right
now the second type is a little bit
counter-intuitive
because he tells us that these are the
ones that are contrived by the poet
themselves and it's very interesting
language that he's using here so uh the
poet is poi taste right so Hoople to POI
Tu means by the poet literally
underneath the poet and then
I right so this is actually coming from
the same root term that we get uh poet
from
poiesis uh poyestai right to make to do
to fabricate to Fashion to produce and
so these are you could say contrived by
the poet but contrived by the poet in
their activity of doing poetry and he
goes on and he says that
um this too is in artistic it's not
according to the tech name right it's
it's uh ah technoy and so he gives some
examples erastes and if Virginia causes
recognition of who he actually is if
ajanya reveals herself by the letter but
a recipe says now here's Rick it's
really interesting says what the poet
um uh you know he he puts words in uh
arreste's mouth right the poetes but not
the story itself not what the plot wants
him to say so what's going on here
Aristotle is actually po you know sort
of Contra uh positioning the poet and
the story itself we we typically think
of well the story is what the poet or
the producer the writer comes up with
but in this case the story is already
partly there and the poet is supposed to
make things fit that story and this is
why it could be less of a good
recognition
the third type that he talks about he
says is through memory the uh names
right how does this work well we're
reminded of something uh seeing hearing
maybe even smelling something brings
awareness and he gives you two really
interesting cases here so the case in
dkogenesis cyprians seeing a painting
the person cries why do they cry because
they they recognize something in the
painting the painting recalls something
to mind and then he brings up the
Odyssey again kind of funny because he's
talking about tragedy but he's also
talking about epic here
um one in Odysseus's tale to al-qinois
hearing the singer
Odysseus is reminded and weeps because
he's hearing a story that he himself is
kind of connected with right so that's a
third type of recognition and this one's
a little bit I mean it seems like it
would be very easy to understand but
um the the examples aren't actually as
apt about you know the Anna gonorasis
that were thinking about here the fourth
one is is very interesting for several
different reasons
so he says recognition by reasoning and
that's an okay translation
literally X
sulugosmo right this is the word we get
syllogism from and if you're used to
thinking about syllogisms in terms of
what we teach in in logic you know uh
all S's P all s is M all m is p
therefore all s is p you know that's one
kind of syllogism but there are many
kinds of syllogisms that Aristotle
discusses in the rhetoric he uses the
word syllogism to mean something a bit
looser in the nick of McCain ethics
there's not only the Practical syllogism
but the uh faculty of of you know uh
anger and desire
syllogizes it puts together arguments so
syllogism can mean something much
broader and we do engage in reasoning
based on things so he talks about
in the Cure forai that somebody like
this person has come nobody is like her
except arrest he's therefore he has come
what is that that's dealing with
necessary stuff that's a that's close to
the typical syllogism right
um but there's also
like he says the recognition used by
polydus the sophist and if a genius case
it was probable he said that arrestes
should reason his sister had been
sacrificed and that his fate was to be
sacrificed to right so this is probable
reasoning this is um aikos this this is
not necessary reasoning and then he even
talks about mistaken reasoning that
people might fall into
um you know para logon is is a way of
thinking about it and then we have a
verb you know Paulo
you know about the the theater and about
other things as well and he says that
this can be the audience's mistaken
reasoning or it can be mistaken
reasoning Within the play itself so he
says um
there is compound recognition which
depends on the audience's mistaken
reasoning as in Odysseus the false
messenger that he and no one else could
bend the bow is contrived by the poet
and a premise even if he said he would
recognize the bow which he had not seen
But to have him recognized by this means
when he was expected to cause
recognition in the other way involves
false reasoning so we can have all kinds
of reasoning reasoning that's actually
correct or we could say valid reasoning
that's probable and then we can have
mistaken reasoning and this can lead to
a recognition of who these characters
are
Aristotle then says the best sort of
recognition doesn't actually come from
any of these it is a rising or ensuing
from the events themselves ex-auton
pragmaton pragmaton are the the events
the things that are being done and you
know Aristotle thinks that the plot is a
system a structure a composition of
these pragmata these these events right
and so he says that
um the emotional impact comes from a
probable sequence for example in
Sophocles Oedipus and the epigenia where
it's probable she would want to entrust
a letter
um only such recognitions do without
contrived tokens and necklaces and then
he sums up I said second best are those
by reason so we've got a clear order of
value According to Aristotle the best
form of recognition the most artistic
form the one that's going to produce the
effects of tragedy is from the events
themselves reasoning is as good memory
is good
messing around with the characters on
the on the part of a poet to sort of
demonstrate you know their own Artistry
is actually in artistic and then by
signs hell anybody can do that Aristotle
would say it's coming from a lack of
Talent OR resources so these are the
different forms or modes of recognition
that Aristotle recognizes himself in
Greek tragedy and then lays out in a
sort of order of value and effectiveness